cancer it's the leading cause of
work-related deaths in the EU with
around 20 million workers exposed to
harmful elements accounts are causing
substances could be anywhere in the air
the walls uniforms machinery and in many
workplaces you could say almost all
sectors but construction sector is one
we often mention different industrial
sectors is service sector MEP is are
updating the rules to better protect
workers from exposure 31 million tonnes
of carcinogens mutagens and other toxins
are produced annually in europe 11 new
chemicals have been added to a list of
substances subject to exposure limits
stricter limits will be imposed for some
elements and exposed workers should have
lifelong health surveillance employers
will have to assess workplace risks and
take preventive measures they you shall
not die from your work you shall enjoy
going to work it shall not be that you
are taking a risk and you can lose your
life Parliament is also calling on the
Commission to include substances harmful
to reproduction in future revisions